you get to ask me to tell you anything  or dare me to do anything and we have  mariah haddad here  mariah what's it gonna be truth or dare  it's gonna be a truth okay so i'm  feeling a little dull lately okay my  truth is  is my outfit boring  oh i did not get boring from your look  at all  i actually think that the tone of your  jacket has a lot of peach in it so it's  sort of like a reinvention of the camel  color  and i think your boots are saying like i  am equestrian chic  i will also say this revelation about  accessories accessories make it look  like you meant to leave the house  add one accessory a necklace a ring a  bracelet an anklet  an earring just one thing and that is  because your outfit's giving me a little  bit of a canvas i want an accessory on  it perfect great advice thank you so  much